I'm ridiculous.
How frustrating was it for you going
into that Tony Ferguson fight with that
staph infection? Because
that was a, that was serious.
I didn't notice it at the weigh ins,
but then the moment you walked
into the cage, it was funny man,
because they were telling DC don't talk
about it cause I was going that staff
that, that is fucking staff. And then they
said to DC, don't talk about it. He goes,
Yup, that looks like staff to me. He
just ignored him. He's like, fuck you.
That's staff.
I don't know why they didn't want
anybody breaking it up because it's an
important point.
It's an unfortunate thing that
happens during training sometimes.
Yeah. Eight. Uh, I kinda notice
it on a Sunday, you know,
in the Tuesday we do the check ins
and everything and uh, I had the girl,
I'm like, can you, you know,
put some makeup on it because I didn't
want nobody to find out. And uh,
even Tony Him, if he would
have saw it, he would have no,
he knew uncompromise all that. Um,
but yeah, it frustrated things.
They make things a lot more complicated.
It put me,
it made the weight cut terrible.
Uh, just to go back to it.
I mean I'm cutting from 76 to to fifties.
I had to be 55 for that fight and I
try my best to skim it down in about 12
hours. So I woke up at 5:00
AM with at about one 62.
Uh, and Wayans are
between nine and 11. Um,
and from 5:00 AM til 8:00 AM I had only
cut one pound compare to in other cuts
that have gone really well.
I'll normally cut bout four or five
pounds in that time. But because I,
I just was feeling good and I wasn't
worried about it and the s and I was using
the same temperature of water,
I was using the same everything,
but the staff made my
body hold onto the water.
So when I went down and checked and saw
that it was still like five pounds up
with like two hours ago,
they started like throwing it,
boiling hot water on me to get my botany.
Yeah,
to give me sweating to get it off. It
was brutal. Yeah. That's for, for know.
For someone who doesn't,
never, never experienced staff.
Explain what does to your body,
it makes you feel the next day.
I just,
I felt so tired.
I never felt as tired
in my life and it felt,
I felt so tired to the point where I tried
to counteract it by getting myself as
pumped as I can. And the, you know,
do you normally get there
two hours before the fight?
When I walked into the arena that night,
two hours before I was in a sweat,
you know,
my body was like full of adrenaline.
Like I wasn't taking any medication.
You weren't going on in antibiotics.
He figured, did you have to decide whether
you should take antibiotics and then,
you know,
that compromises your endurance for sure.
Or just let your body fight it off.
I had it before I had been on the
antibiotics and they just make terrible,
you know, if you've ever been through
it. I mean, it's a terrible feeling.
So I just was like, you know what?
I think I can just push through it.
And I'm young and I was like, you know
what, fuck it. Like let's just go like,
did you try any like a
natural remedies oil?
You know,
it wasn't a whole lot I could take,
cause I also got to cut the
weight still. Right. You know, uh,
some topical stuff that one of the
things they say that works really well,
topical, believe it or
not is mince. Garlic.
Garlic apparently has a tremendous
effect on staph infections.
I was swallowing whole cloves of ginger.
I remember I would take gender,
I would chop it up and I'll swallow
it, uh, to see if that would do some.
But you know, it's, yeah,
it's a hard battle cause some real
strong antibacterial properties.
And one of the people that have
been on the podcast, many times,
Doctor Rhonda Patrick said she,
she had dealt with some persistent
staph infection and she had like a whole
inner skin. And what she did was she
took garlic and packed it into that hole.
Jen and fucking killed it. I mean, Geez,
I wish I would've known that before.
I just kinda just fought through it.
I was like, fuck it, I'm just going.
Defense soap makes some really good stuff.
That too,
they make us these essential oils.
It's tea tree oil and eucalyptus oil
and you put it on like right where they
have an issue. Where were you in in
October would have been there for you.
Anybody else there that has that staff?
Anytime you have any sort of a
ringworm or staff or anything,
there's some natural stuff. Not like
some bullshit homeopathic nonsense,
but some actual real natural
stuff that can help you.
And Defense soap specializes
in that because a guy sacco,
the guy who owns the
company, he is, you know,
coaches wrestling and deals with kids.
I'd always have ringworm staph infection,
so she can,
he came out with these soaps.
He's natural soaps that are
just designed for grapplers.
It's why it's called defense
soap. No. And then, um,
I'll have them send you some and then
the essential oils and balms and stuff
like ointments for scratches and shit
like that. So they don't get infected.
That's, you know, Jim's,
it's, you're always getting
infected. Yeah. And that's it.
That was one of the biggest
focuses that this canvas,
just like make sure I stay healthy because
they, if you don't have your health,
you don't have nothing.
And that was what it was at that
Tony fight and it's just, it,
it became something I didn't want to.
It was such a big event and it was my
first real big event to a that I just
wanted it all just to
go right and go over.
But it ended up being just a lot of my,
by the staff originally.
I think it came from mental
stress, you know, it,
it was so many stresses going on,
you know, you really sure. Yeah.
You and you look at the three
biggest stressors, you know,
I was going through a divorce and
I had just moved into a house.
You look at those in a normal day to day
life that though those are like the two
biggest stressors.
You can have a then to add on fighting
for a world title in six weeks.
So I'm just like fucking go. Like, I was
like, you know, I wouldn't expect them to,
I was thinking maybe a,
they was gonna give me Tony,
but maybe in December indeed and in
Detroit or if something like that,
but he was like six weeks. I was
like, hi, what fog does, right.
They were thinking about doing you in
Detroit. Right. That was a, that was,
that was the talk. And you were
requesting a big fight in Detroit. Yeah,
that's where all my, like, you know,
every year I kind of Chore
Plan Out my year and a, and a,
and I got my vision in my head. Uh, I
got to call them water bowls in there.
That was one of them.
But yeah,
it ended up putting a little bit
too much stress on me all at once.
And I took on a lot for that one. But
you did learn dot. Tell you what, man,
when you took him down and mounted him
and the first round I was like, Holy Shit,
cause I know how good
Tony is on the green.